Just realized that I
typed in the wrong numbers
at the end of the
last video when
I was trying to put
them in the calculator.
We were trying to determine the
coefficient of static friction,
and it's 50 newtons divided by
49 square roots of 3 newtons.
And in the last video, by
accident, in the calculator,
instead of doing 49
square roots of 3,
I wrote 40 square roots of 3.
So let's actually
calculate it again.
50 divided by 49 times--
let me write it this way,
make sure we get-- 49
times the square root of 3
gives us a coefficient of static
friction of, if we round it,
0.59.
So this is equal to 0.59.
And so that's it.
I just forgot to-- I
did the calculation
wrong on the calculator
in the last video.